[Musique]
et nicolas zeit d'un ancien ami josh
freese week secret dame noirmont man
with big nose defenders of the boring
dans l'autre chambre
c'est évident que cette citation du
président dans notre chambre étape et
n'est pas crédible est absolument
ridicule
les températures au dessus des moyens
ont été ont été enregistrés pour la
première fois en 1998 et depuis cette
année sans faute et ne cesse d'augmenter
ce qui veut dire que moi et ma
génération n'avons jamais vécu et connu
un un climat typiquement canadien le
canada se réchauffe deux fois plus vite
que le reste de la planète
un rapport a été émis au début du mois
en avril 2019 par lé département du
réchauffement climatique du gouvernement
du québec
citant que les effets du réchauffement
climatique était définitivement
irréversible et puis que les humains
étaient la cause première de ceux ci les
plusieurs facteurs à fait clair team
dont l'angle de la tanière l'homme
l'orbité de la terre autour du soleil
est aussi les changements des courants
océaniques
mais soyons en être avec nous mêmes
c'est clair que ces facteurs n'ont aucun
rapport avec ce qui se passe en ce
moment nous les humains n'avons que nous
à blâmer pour ce post catastrophe que la
planète se détériore et nous devons
prendre conscience de ceux ci
l'augmentation des niveaux de dioxyde de
carbone seulement peut expliquer
pourquoi la planète se réchauffe les
excès de carbone se propage dans
l'atmosphère quand nous prenons notre
tour car nous allons faire l'épicerie
temps nous réchauffons de maisons tout
simplement le dioxyde de carbone se
propage quand nous vivons
notre vie quotidienne en 2007 la
colombie britannique avec qui a été
succombé par enfant ayant brûlé 1.2
milliard millions d'hectares en deux
semaines consécutives l'année suivante
la colombie-britannique a été vue avoir
brûlé 1.35 million d'hectares et ceci en
seulement deux semaines
ceci est malheureux 1 étude fait par
l'université victoria et changement
climatique canada on évaluer comment
comment le réchauffement climatique joue
un rôle important dans ces deux feux ils
ont évalué
comment un environnement peuplé et un
environnement désert or et comment les
deux il aurait montré comment ils
joueraient un rôle
l'étude a conclu que dans une étude dans
un environnement peuplé la probabilité
car feu commençait était depuis le 95 %
en 2016
la guilde forte mais cnri ou qu'elle a
une grande partie de ma famille à dieu a
été submergée d'un flux à ce jour si ce
faire est considéré comme le désastre
naturel le plus dispendieux de
l'histoire du canada et a été évaluée à
9 points 9 milliards de dollars
le québec est grandement affectée par
les changements climatiques ou si il le
charge les changements climatiques
aggravent et augmente les vagues de
chaleur que nous vivons pendant l'été ce
site n'est ni ne semble pas important et
pas très dangereuse mais celles ci
peuvent être fatales pour des aînés pour
les jeunes enfants et pour les personnes
ayant des maladies chroniques aussi les
riches changement climatique augmente
les innovations qui peuvent causer des
millions de dollars de rêve de réparé de
réparation et aussi nos routes sont
gravement affectées par le changement
climatique car quand elle la star des
géants à cause de l'heure
la température élèves ceci ferait des
glissements de terrain et ceci est très
important et dangereux car elle que
causer des accidents de taux quand la
température élèves l'atmosphère devient
vulnérable à la pub pollution elle ceci
augmente à temps la période d'allergies
et aussi rend la population en danger
car il peut avoir des feux de forêt
récurer courant je vais vous proposer
quelques façons de non seulement vous
adapter mais aussi de changer
donc stop breathing energy société so
you can entre trois et six minutes
d'interview things you can en so we do
they tempétueuses hors du cac en saut
reduce reuse mais sa copine crampes aux
beats by dre distance de 12 km à revoir
meet you need to produce de prades
elle pense au campo sting et michael
green growth casse tête
l organisme a re ly quang ngai film
fight and organic malheureuse qui
composent des mes gars n'ont à ce
meeting and gas ltd population non et
les importune aux dates world outside
nord est des états unis les extras
il est préférable physical activity des
domaines hors énergie rivale fitch
trucks ans au biscione tout chaque effet
à beauval et murs abeilles ce même tour
de france fera des émules
avant m
aston villa est unique sur ok andy
cropper
finalement la citation de dans notre
champ et s'est vue envers le changement
climatique sont un peu farfelu oui mais
nous ne voulons nous nous n'avons plus
le choix d'agir nous n'avons plus le
droit de fermer l'oeil et d'ignorer et
de laisser les générations futures
d'agir nous devons faire ceci maintenant
nous voulons nous voulions être plus
riche et plus accessible nous voulions
que notre ville soit plus facile en
faisant ceci nous avons créé un monstre
ce qui est le réchauffement climatique
ceux ci et là temps d'agir nous devons
ouvrir nos yeux ceci est notre maman
inquiète
[Applaudissements]